salut les amis c'est squeeze et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour ma toute
première vidéo bonus donc spécial 200
abonnés donc une vidéo commentée en live
sur minecraft en bon français je le
rappelle mais je ne suis pas seul
écoutez j'ai une superbe idée c'est
vraiment comme je suis relativement nul
à ce jeu que enfin vraiment je n'ai pas
beaucoup joué j'ai pas beaucoup
d'imagination enfin bref charmant pourri
donc je proposais à mon ami de venir de
venir chez moi de jouer à côté de moi et
puis pourquoi pas je lui demande ce
qu'il fait on commente ensemble puis on
voit ensemble avec vous les différents
aspects du jeu donc mon ami scénique ce
beau jour nous salue donc donc c'est
parti donc on jouait la bêta 1.4 donc je
vous cache pas encore une fois que n'en
laisse laisse nous annonçons fiche je
vous cache pas vraiment qu'on a qu'on
n'a pas acheté le jeu comme d'abord
votre faim on compte on compte peut-être
l'acheter mais pour le moment non
écoutez on n'a pas vraiment la tête à ça
pour ce genre de jeu pour le moment
donc si vous êtes assez je sais pas
j'aime faire des rondes accord donc il
donc donc lui donc je disais vraiment
google votre ami si vous ne voulez pas
payer le jeu donc excusez moi si ça lag
m'écouter frappe ceux n'en fait qu'à sa
tête dans ce jeu pourtant c'est
graphiquement pourri enfin je trouve un
moment le jeu à son charme vraiment le
jeu à son charme
donc on commence c'est ça il fait jour
donc d'après ce que j'ai compris il y a
dix minutes de jour dix minutes de nuit
dans le jeu donc les dix minutes deux
jours vous permettront de récolter
beaucoup de ressources et doute faire un
petit abri avant la nuit et lorsque la
nuit tombe des monstres veulent vous
tuez veulent fera s'acharne contre vous
et donc il vous faut un abri et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut le construire pendant
le jour donc pendant la nuit qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire en fait pendant un hub
à dormir dans d'accord alors à grandir
agrandir sa maison si si elle n'est pas
assez grande et puis voilà ah oui c'est
vrai que l'on peut qu on peut construire
des lits ouais alors les lycées c'est
samba jeu
kraft après la donc en fait les nih
permettent de passer la nuit sur voilà
c'est ça lui a manqué un petit clic
droit sur le 10 puis voilà et si le
risque est donc c'est cool donc alors là
déjà on va commencer par les colts et du
bois moi je commence à en récolter 10 15
20 par là parce que c'est super c'est
vachement le bois c'est selon moi ce qui
est plus utile dans le jeu ce qui permet
de tout faire au début après nada après
ceux qui connaissent bien le jeu vont
faire des trucs en diamant qui coûte
avant d'être marquée comme des gt
d'ailleurs au tgp vous je vous invite
tous à aller voir sa chaîne serment à un
mec qui fait de bonnes vidéos si vous
voulez aller voir sa chaîne n'hésitez
pas je mettrais bien dans la description
où il s'affichera maintenant là tout de
suite oui donc je disais il fait des
épisodes comme moi un peu comme mes
sauts let's go donc allé voir si vous
voulez hein enfin bon revenons donc à
mille crève donc là tu es donc en train
de récolter du bois afin de faire des
instruments donc comme des payes dh et
d'aimer quand des pioches seulement donc
les instruments servent à récolter plus
vite par exemple la pioche permet dé
côté lapierre plus vite la hache permet
de récolter le bois plus vite
l'appel permet de récolter la le sable
et la terre plus vite etc
je connais pas tous par terre non plus
donc ce qu'on peut faire aussi c'est que
s'ils voulaient kraft correspondent en
fait donc on verra tout à l'heure quand
mon cher ami knicks crafter à des trucs
en fait le soul et l'apparence du craf
correspond à l'objectif c'est à dire si
on met une pioche on mettra trois tubes
en eau et de cubes pour faire le
manchois vous verrez ça tout à l'heure
quand mon ami assez long là tu as dit
cette boîte ouais c'est ça donc alors
déjà je vais commencer par kraft et mes
petits bon alors on prend un bois on le
met dans la tête de karting et là on va
on va transformer ça en planches de bois
j'ai fini attaque
c maximum ses 64 du même ressource donc
ensuite on dépose clic droite littoraux
clic clic droit et là ça fait une belle
table de kraft l'accord donc mettez bien
en voilà et d'y avoir apparemment dans
mais il faut bien mettre sur moi je me
souviens que les premiers tuto que
j'avais vu en fait je m'étais comme lui
le même nombre de trucs mais je m'étais
pas à ce que ça correspondait dans les
15-20 vous verse à tout à l'heure
nokia n8 la table de kraft s'est elle
permet ça fait en fait il ya neuf cases
alors que dans l'inventaire il y en a
que gardent les lieux n'a que 4 est donc
là on va pouvoir commencer à faire
quelques petits objets donc par exemple
si on fait ça et ça ça fera des manches
qui vont être bien utile pour faire des
outils d'accord et puis là j'ai pas si
le matériau pour faire d'autres choses
donc alors tout est transportable par
exemple ça je reprends ma table je la
prends avec moi donc là qu'est ce que je
vaux au dessus là il ya une petite
falaise avec avec du charbon avec du
charbon c'est sale ça va être super high
d'observer que sur les îles à différents
matériaux notamment duo d'egypte et qui
partaient à la chasse au diamant si me
souviens bien
enfin je prends un des gp comme
référence parce que vraiment je n'ai
entendu sur sky beaucoup jouer donc il
disait du diamant nous n'avons machin le
cas du diamant du charbon de la pierre
du sable de la terre et avec chaque
matériau on peut faire un nouveau
matériau par exemple je sais que si on
si on combine deux sable ça fera un
espèce de de ça mais je crois que ces
quatre c4
c'est le 4 4 4 salles d'accor sa sur
parce que j'avais pas en matériel que
jean d'accord bah oui de quel est donc
ce sera grâce à deux plus beaux ciblées
et et qui sera pas soumis à la gravité
comme le sable normal donc là tu prends
ton charbon donc on pourra aussi faire
des des lampes avec le charbon des
langues qui permettent pour dans la
nuite c'est clair un peu se sent donc
cette vidéo est vraiment fait pour les
débutants de mai ne connais pas les
joueurs avancés si vous êtes un jour
avancé vous devez littéralement vous
faire chier car cette vidéo n'est pas un
tutoriel mais plutôt une découverte du
jeu ou une explication du jeu coûte et
j'espère que vous faites pas trop chien
pour ceux qui se font chier je mettrais
peut-être un je mettrais un diaporama
d'image de shalla à l'écran quelle bonne
idée un corps très bonne idée mais ça je
vais me faire une petite pioche en bois
déjà pour commencer voilà donc à temps
pour faire rougir les jo je vous en fait
les deux frères des biens alors on va on
va donner la forme de l'objet dont klaus
à faire le bon choix et donc là on va
mettre 3 pour faire la forme de la pile
à 100 $ par exemple si on en mentionnant
bien là et qu'on enlève celui-là ça fait
une hache
ça fait une page d'accord si on enlève
les deux là c'est acquis tac tac ça fait
une peine voilà donc c'est vraiment la
forme de l'objet désiré donc ça c'est
assez marrant quand même c'est bien
pensé
vraiment c'est assez bien pensé donc
écoute dépêche toi parce qu'il ya
bientôt faire lui bon voilà en fait
j'avais un problème si pas pourquoi à
mains nues mais j'arrive pas à récolter
le charbon donc là problèmes résolus
voilà une pioche au niveau graphique a
vraiment c'est pas top mais écoutez
c'est plutôt sympa c'est plutôt au début
personnellement j'étais un prétentieux
je disais ouais grave c'est nul et tout
est en fait plus on joue plus on devient
addictif ce jeu est extrêmement addictif
donc les âmes sensibles qui deviennent
très vite accro je ne jouais surtout pas
à ce jeu puisque là vous vous aurez
littéralement mappy d'amis des mauvaises
notes et plus de vie quoi donc m maille
à l'école voilà très surtout travaillé à
l'école le travail c'est bien les amis
une can find the job after after school
si tu as bien travaillé enfin bon l
anglais a remarqué la marque à la joie
que je travaille bien voilà alors là je
pense que ça va suffire comme charbon je
vais ramasser la pierre ce que lapierre
ça peut être utile aussi qu'on soit des
belles maisons
non pas que battu donc pour pour les
instruments ah oui c'est vrai ma
fonction un petit four sound six-fours
un petit feu aux rideaux qu'un four qui
sert à construire l'avion dit j'ai bien
compris pour récupérer ses points de vie
après s'être fait attaquer par des
méchants monstres c'est cela c'est ça ou
alors avoir fait une super chute par
exemple un geronimo voilà points
c'est d'en faire un petit jogging
d'accord on va vous montrer ce qu'on
appelle un jour animaux alors là je
pense que ça suffira
je vais récupérer la table de krav wayne
j'oublie quoi c'est trop un petit coin
sympa parce que c'est ça qui va faire
bien tenu mais presque mais presque
donc je voulais y revenir sur les deux
spéciales de sang de suzanne et fassions
200 abonnés donc je voulais vous dire
que en fait j'avais dit que je ferais
une vidéo pas en live sur modern warfare
2 donc je maintiens elle ne sera pas en
live mais ma vidéo sur d'espèces 2
plutôt que mettre monde ma tête en bas à
droite
enfin moi en train de jouer en bas à
droite de l'écran sur moder warfare 2 eh
ben je mettrais plutôt sur dead space 2
vous pourrez voir mes réactions quand
j'ai peur
ah bon ce sera pas des trucs non plus
georges saute de ma chaise
j'ai peur non ça sera quand même assez
sain ce n'est m'écouter j'espère que ça
vous plaira vous me direz donc cette
vidéo minecraft elle sortira tout à
l'heure sur youtube en bas alors aulas a
une épée donc encore bien voilà ce que
j'ai vu des cochons j'aime pas les
cochons je vais les tuer pour être pas
dû les gars car les cochons ça permet de
re la viande voilà donc là j'ai eu deux
petits morceaux de viande et voilà
vaïsse c'est ça ressemble pas trop mais
c'est une vache c'est ingrat un espèce
de gros cubes
donc voilà on peut récupérer du cuir sur
les vaches ne vais pas reculer réduire
qui ça à ce qu'autant des armes ici on
va te couper c'est ça c'est exactement
ça et je vais pas trop récupéré parce
que après ça prend beaucoup de place
dans l inventaire surtout que ça peut
pas se cumuler
mais tandis que ça ça vaut ce cumul est
donc je vais à explorer un peu ce monde
qui m'a l'air plutôt pas mal
ce que le monde le monde très aléatoire
on tue on peut tomber sur mon pourri où
tu as apparaîtra que rien ne te retiens
de citrouilles des citrouilles et
généralement ça que j'ai jamais vu j'en
avais entendu parler lors c'est super à
quoi ça sert aof une idée je sais que
quand on met une torche dans une
citrouille je crois ça te fait une
citrouille lumineuse entre comme ça c
c'est très stressant de mansaly lol lol
je vous invite aussi allait voir les
vidéos de mon jeune ami commentateurs
qui commençait commentaire donc ci sera
surtout axé sur les mmorpg donc
notamment riveta vraiment réagir au
niveau jeu en demo foulée un giro nous
attend mais repas je vais essayer
attention aux balles à la jambe droite
donc un fils je viens de manger une
petite viande comme ça pour récupérer ta
ville a un très bel exemple voilà enfin
vraiment très bizarre
hop une petite vache ça je pourrais vous
montrer si j'en ai assez haut
tu la gardes d'or en ski patron
maintenant ouais on pas au mythe était
là c'est nous pardon qui alors là y'a
pas tardé à faire mieux je veux pas ce
que je peux faire un autre pas t'as pas
beaucoup de cul pour construire ta
cabane là quand même du cube
je fais pas je vais seaway je sais pas
si j'aurai le temps de construire une
cabane donc donc j'allais dire tu de tes
dépêcher alors hop
certes pas si c'est bon c'est bon tu as
et a refusé dimanche
oula oula la houlala il fait nuit des
pêches dépêche toi là commence à avoir
peur allez allez allez vu assure un
petit h pourquoi ou la halle et des
pêches et à kiel d'ubifrance proton bois
les tombeaux à la base d'un piscine mais
t'inquiète il ya toujours moyen au pied
en skrela l'est et même 6 ha oui au pire
tu le creuser un tunnel pour y là où on
a
lundi mossawa non non non des moutons
mais merde
non mais là dans la salle rigoler la
dépêche toi
à onna au pire je bute les héninois ya
un mois il ya zéro problème
ouais un petit mouton ça ferait plaisir
puisque aaa le voilà et un terme donné
trois les soirs je vais buts et toute sa
famille oh oui pardon excusez nous ces
jeux est vraiment très olalalala il fait
nuit la cache toi vite ça je sais pas si
j'en ai pris 3 je vais m'assurer de ces
bons alors où la rue là là là ça
commence à faire peur mais qui alors là
on est sur minecraft donc imaginer sur
dead space 2 ce que ça va être à quai ce
qui est un signe là oh là là à voir la
tête est mort on voit plus rien des
pêches narnia raquette up solution mais
voilà alors hop une petite torche à lui
il a même bien utile et inquiète être
qui n'a pas voilà on est pas sorti
d'affaires pour damer ferme ferme
derrière toi moi si voilà qui attaque et
en supplie ferme faire mal et et non
mais j'peux pas là je suis pas encore
assez profond alors venez faire vite
mais t'es con alors voilà il allait
voilà allez hop demi tour et là il ya un
monstre qui tue up fin du commentaire
oui c'est la fin merci à vous d'avoir
regardé la vidéo bas parce qu'elle est à
l'amp jeu l'enfermer de l'autre côté à
super e/o 1
voilà alors je gagnais je vais agrandir
ma petite maison parce que là je ne sais
pas que je suis claustrophobe et prêts à
moi j'aime bien alors voilà je trouve ça
sympa c'est que c'est pas bon je pense
que l'ami on va vous la passe et puisque
ça va être ou alors non non vous la
passe et c'est ce que je m'amuse à fait
surpris
bruce willis moi je pense à nos halls
qui les mondiaux alors hop je vais à
grandir mon petit habitacle
oui oui shakespeare on m'appelle tout à
fait oui alors hop voilà jamais j'ai un
petit peu arrondie alors c'est pas c'est
pas un truc d'architectes je vous
préviens gigaba voilà et bah voilà alors
taxi me souviens bien nu nuls vraiment
alors je crois que c'est ça je ne
m'insulte est patent des poèmes des
sticks en dessous donc pour faire genre
d des pieds à temps tétouan d'accord
voilà examen la la la la la la
mais j'ai profité pour me refaire des
petits instants l'alabama un vierge mère
fait une petite pierre à la lah pardon
oui certes c'est bon je vais augmenter
la sensibilité jusque là je la trouvais
trop basse pour l'eau-de-vie certes
c'est mieux aussi mettez vos
commentaires pour dire ce que vous
pensez de minecraft vraiment mon avis
mais n'en faut pas moins mon avis
personnellement attention mesdames et
messieurs dans un instant la vie d'un
squeeze sur le jeu minecraft doing
eybens et 1,15